incluyan a las mujeres es el pedido que
varias afganas por segundo día
consecutivo hacen en las calles de kabul
al nuevo gobierno de los talibanes
deben asegurarse de que las mujeres
participen en su gobierno sabemos que
las mujeres constituyen la mayor parte
de la población afgana si ellas no son
implicadas en la educación la salud y la
política y si ellas no juegan un rol en
el seno de nuestra sociedad el mundo no
nos reconocerá nada navasal ante la
espera del anuncio de la composición de
un nuevo gobierno las mujeres temen que
ocurra lo mismo que en los años 90 donde
los talibanes instauraron un régimen
misógino en el que los derechos de las
mujeres se restringieron en un listado
que incluía la prohibición de salir a la
calle sin ser acompañados por un hombre
de trabajar de asistir a las escuelas y
hasta reírse en voz alta en
contraposición las afganas presentaron
un documento con sus propias demandas
cuarto libertad de expresión
participación activa y diplomática a
nivel nacional quinto las mujeres que
trabajen en todas las oficinas
relevantes deben regresar a sus puestos
de trabajo actuales
siguen los talibanes han mostrado una
cara más moderada dando anuncios como el
del ministro interino de educación quien
dijo que las mujeres podrán asistir a
las universidades algunas mujeres han
anunciado amenazas y en irak una de las
ciudades más importantes del país varias
comunicaron que las han retirado de sus
puestos de trabajo cuando el visual 2 en
los últimos 20 años nosotras las mujeres
hemos participado en todos los aspectos
de la vida hombro a hombro con los
hombres por lo tanto nadie puede
eliminar nos nota
todas
por ahora la situación de las mujeres en
afganistán es incierta por lo que muchas
esperan el anuncio de los talibanes
mientras que otras ya abandonaron el
país